[Music]
we're so used to seeing studio logos at
the beginning of movies like paramount
mountain Disney's castle and DreamWorks
Moon but do you know the true stories
behind each of them watch the video to
find out who's the little boy in
DreamWorks logo if this is your first
time visiting our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we're sharing 10
true stories behind Hollywood studio
logos Walt Disney Company the Magic
Castle logo is synonymous with Walt
Disney movies but believe it or not the
company didn't bring in that logo until
1985 Walt Disney was established 62
years before that in 1923 before 1985 it
just used different stylized versions of
the words Walt Disney presents the
castle logo has gone through some
changes over the years too in 1990 it
was a simple White Castle revealing
itself on a blue background and in 2006
it became a very detailed scene based on
a real building in Europe
metro-goldwyn-mayer the
metro-goldwyn-mayer roaring lion is kind
of terrifying when you're a kid
publicist Howard Diaz originally
designed it for Goldwyn picture
corporation he based it on the athletics
club mascot of his alma mater Columbia
University the logo stayed when three
Studios merged to become MGM in 1924
several lines have been used over the
years including slats jackie kelly
coffee
Tanner George and now Leo the motto on
the logo ARS gratia artis is Latin for
art for art's sake Columbia the torch
lady in Columbia's logo has undergone
various changes since 1924 she started
out dressed as a Roman soldier
she was then draped in an American flag
which was later replaced by a blue drape
in the 1990s illustrator Michael Diaz
redesigned the logo do you know what
inspired Diaz when he was painting the
model Jenny Joseph was simply holding up
a regular lamp during her lunch break it
is surprising to see the result when we
think about this Warner Brothers the
Warner Bros logo has gone through a few
changes over the years the first version
in 1923 head WB on the bottom half of a
shield with a photo of the Burbank
studio building on the top half the WB
then filled the shield in front of a
cloud filled sky from the 19
Bertie's as it does today but from 1972
and 1984 at the studio dropped the
shield and used a W in a circle this
became the logo for Warner Music Group
Pixar the lab in the Pixar logo was
actually the star of the corporation's
first short movie in that two minutes
shorts a lamp called luxo jr. wants to
play ball with his father lexo senior he
accidentally deflates the ball the short
ends with luxo jr. bringing in a much
bigger beach ball in the logo luxo jr.
is cordless and he jumps down on top of
the I of the word Pixar like you stomped
on the ball by the way that ball shows
up in most Pixar films did you see this
fall in one of your favorite Pixar
movies tell us where you saw it in the
comments 20th Century Fox Fox Film
corporation and 20th century pictures
merged in 1935 to create 20th Century
Fox artist Emile cosas jr. designed the
logo as an art deco monolith with
searchlights when Fox began releasing
movies in widescreen in the 1950s the 0
in 20th was tilted so the monolith still
looks proportional the zero got
straightened again in the 1980s the logo
was recreated in CGI in 1994 and again
in 2008 United Artists the United
Artists logo has gone through lots of
different designs it initially stayed
the same for a long time from 1919 to
the late 1960s it was simply the words
United Artists inside a hexagon then it
went very colorful for a couple of years
blue lines forming at E were introduced
to the logo in the early 1970s it went
gold then back to the blue t and then
had a redesign in the early 1980s a blue
line revealed the initials UA then it
went back to selling out the whole two
words in the 1990s then it reverted to
UA this time in silver after so many
changes it is difficult to recognize
United Artists over the years paramount
power mounts majestic mountain logo has
been around since the corporation's
beginning in fact it's Hollywood's
oldest surviving movie studio logo and
it all started with the doodle
WW Hodgkinson sketched the ben lomond
mountain from his beautiful childhood
and that became the logo later versions
of the mountain are thought to be based
on a peak in the Peruvian Andes there
were originally
twenty-four stars around the peak one
for each of the 24 actors under contract
in 1916 but in the more recent versions
that number reduced to 22 Universal the
globe has remained a constant feature of
the universal logo but it's gone through
various transformation from the 1920s a
plane circled around a spinning globe
it left a smoke trail that spells out
the studio's names
sparkling stars were added in the 1930s
as the years went by computer-generated
versions of the clove appeared like in
its 100th anniversary logo the globe has
been set against sunrise and sunset
DreamWorks when Steven Spielberg founded
DreamWorks in 1994 he had a vision of a
computer-generated man fishing from the
moon for the logo visual effects
supervisor Dennis Muren suggested it
should be hand-painted artist Robert
hunt did the honors he also did a
version with a boy instead of a man
using his son William as the model and
that's the version they went with how
about the SKG
it stands for Spielberg and founders
captain Berg and Gavin's
which of these true stories behind
Hollywood studio logos did you find the
most interesting let us know in the
comments and remember to give us a big
thumbs up
[Music]